it's like caligulous playground it's so
over the top
the hedonism and debauchery
and and the lawlessness man i mean he
got homeless robbing homeless and
people stepping over other people when
they're they're
you know using drugs and whatnot
how long you guys been here
so we've been
we've been out here
homeless now about
uh about a year and three months
yeah
yeah we came down like january
see we um
joey uh
i had to do a little i i finished up my
probation and and and all that um when i
came home
joey uh he knows that i like machines he
was working around uh these neat
machines and i'm kind of a machinist by
trade so i went into his work and uh
checked out the machine i got a job and
you know the boss
was you know tickled how excited i was
about the machines
so he said you know you want to try it
out i said sure you know so he got me a
job there man he was working out great
close you know friendly people
um
eventually
my daughter got a job there joey's
sister got a job there so i mean we were
doing great
we were working um
we were using drugs
but uh we were going we were going to
work you know you were using we were
using you know not at work right but
right before you know and you're a
functional addict see the story well
there's no such thing that's what i was
just saying uh
the thing was
i don't know how familiar you are with
the scene here but um you know the the
dope heroine
is what the the drug of choice was and
slowly it just turned into fentanyl
you know and
that i i really don't like you know i
mean the the the heroin you know
is bad enough but
you could wake up in the morning eat
your breakfast do a little bit
go off to work and be fine
um
with this fentanyl crap and whatever
they're putting in it man i mean within
two hours you're you're gonna have to
use it again and it you know you know
telling what it's gonna do one time it
doesn't do anything the next time it it
makes you fall asleep you know it's just
so up and down it's it's just like
maintenance man
you don't you you pay money
basically to go to sleep anymore it's
not
it's no longer fun you know not that it
was really ever that fun
not much joy left in
it's a chore but you can't just put it
down and stop
i'm about ready to tell you the truth i
mean it's
it's that bad you know what i mean i'm
not getting
i'm speaking for myself i don't know
about joey
well i'm not getting anything out of it
you know what i mean i'm really not
there no enjoyment anymore it's like
you know it's a hassle and then when you
get it it's like oh here we go you know
and it's to come down and get it it's
like oh where are we going to go to get
it today and what was good yesterday
stinks today and
it's just it's turning into too much
more than it's worth yeah yeah what was
your childhood like where you grew up
where
i grew up in
pennsylvania here in bucks county
my childhood was great man i had a
mother father
um older brother older sister
my brother larry was what five years
older than me
janet my sister is
two years older than him so you know
she's about six and a half seven years
older than me
she passed good childhood um great
childhood man um i was a little slow in
school i won't stay slow
you know i acted up i acted up a little
bit in school you know um
but i always i was always into reading
so the teacher would say read chapter
one i'd read the whole book
so if i had my head down and the teacher
called on me they were mad because i
knew the answers um
dumb trivial stuff they'd suspend me for
wearing my hat and you know all dumb
stuff like that
i was into uh
my family was great my father worked at
the steel mill he was a master
electrician
he was the
not just a baseball coach or manager he
was the president for the whole league
my mother was the
president of the ladies auxiliary so you
know what i mean i they were into it
um
i was kind of a star in baseball i i
don't want to say a star but
you know it my dad really
really really uh helped me out when i
was a kid you know he he always had time
to go out and have a catch you know
uh he worked with me pitching so i
became a pitcher you know i pitched in
vet stadium you know before they tore it
down
um
we did pretty good you know met a lot of
friends
and uh
even when i was older you know when i
was married to his mother i was on a
adult uh adult softball league that was
great
um
how'd you end up in this situation we
just finally got out of the uh the
sports now see the whole time
i was using the
i would always use drugs but
the
i always never used heroin never
i mean i've had a job where my boss used
every day and i said please don't show
me it don't do it around me don't ask me
what are you using like in high school
uh i would what like through high school
and stuff smoking pot um
you know cocaine every once in a while
we we take an acid trip every once in a
while
mess every once in a while like speed
and forgetting something
yeah oh drinking yeah see drinking was
my
drinking was my crutch i drank a lot see
my fat my parents drank um
and their parents before their parents
they they were alcoholics but they were
naive you know they always you know paid
the bills raised us we always had food
and clothes and whatnot so
that generation you know what i mean um
i guess they looked at it different my
dad and my mom never thought of alcohol
as a drug they never really understood
how
somebody couldn't just put it down you
know what i mean they did they didn't
understand it as a sickness i'm not sure
they were ever really taught or told too
much about that
but uh oh yeah man when i was you know
11 12 years old we'd come home from the
baseball games and you know our dads and
the coaches you'd be like hey kids you
can have a beer
you know what i mean that just
progressed into you know well we're
gonna have we're gonna have a couple
friends up and drink a casey beer we'll
stay here you know what i mean
and then it just turned into
i always drank you know i mean i drank
at work
um
it was never fired because of it um i
always hit it i didn't hide it from the
family i drank everybody said you know
why don't you just quit drinking
um
and i never had the want to i said when
i'm ready i will you know uh how old are
you now
now i'm 52
and i quit drinking you know about three
years ago
you know two three no rehab no no
nothing like that you know i'm not
superman i just you replaced it with
fentanyl though i wore it out well no i
was drinking when i was doing that for a
little while and then it just
you know like like the fentanyl it just
it wasn't what it used to be you know i
mean
and you know it was a waste of money
my health was going you know you start
to
lose the enjoyment you used to get out
of it yeah it's not there anymore yeah
they spent an all crap drains you man i
mean
to be honest with you it's so depressing
anymore that
you you know you you lose
grip you know i don't i don't even have
dreams anymore you know i always wanted
this that and the other
and anymore it's like
whatever you know and it's a shame
because you know i got a lot of life
left
and uh but now you and your son are both
homeless a lot of children yeah we're
both homeless
um joey's a great kid joey had a couple
tough breaks his mother died
when he was
eight
and
my daughter his his full-blown sister
was 11. um
his mom was getting headaches and
whatnot her eyes hurt so doctors said
well we'll go get a
mri for shits and giggles and
and it turned out she had a tumor on her
brain
and uh
what's it a astro hematoma or well you
know some kind of
aneurysm
and what they what they did was they
uh they they gave her medicine um
they
did a couple surgeries where they
removed the skull you know for the
swelling and whatnot gave her the
radiation treatment she did a little
chemo
and it just wasn't enough man when they
told her she was cancer-free she died a
week later
they think
well it was it was like an aneurysm the
day she died or the night she died um
she was supposed to have like a yard
sale with joey and his sister jessica
and uh so jessica came and got me and
said you know dad mommy's not answering
the door can you come up and you know
get us in i said all right
so
it was kind of unusual so i went up and
uh knocked on the door and whatnot and
there was no answer
and by the end jess was like breaking
the door breaking noises yes i'm not
about to break in this door if your
mother's got a date or something in
there
and uh
after a little while we started worrying
and putting you know two and two
together and saying well we're gonna
have to get in and see what's going on
uh like joey was saying a little while
ago my father was maintenance for the
park
so we we flagged him down
and he cut the chain on the door
and
me
amy and my father went in and and we saw
that she had passed
you know so we had called and they
they believe it was just an aneurysm you
know i mean i could tell by the way
she was that she had died before she hit
the ground you know no pain no suffering
i never seen so many adults crying yeah
that day
she she was well loved by her family and
friends she was great
everybody was crying at the hell yeah
every every adult i've seen
that day was crying yeah
real pretty man
she uh she looked like the blonde from
two broke girls i mean gorgeous
joe how would you describe your
childhood
i i had a good childhood um
you know i had a
a bum deal you know my with my mother
being taken away like that
but i had
um good grandparents
whose parents yeah they really stepped
up they were good and uh
you know they raised me and
they were there for me when uh i needed
them
so it wasn't uh
you know it wasn't wasn't the best
anybody could have like like we said you
know
i was short a mother but
it was still good there was still good
good times to be had
yeah we always did have fun very active
family you know joe's got a lot of
sisters
we'd always be out front you know
playing ball
where i've got um
eight half sisters and one sister
yeah so
a big family
oh let me tell you when joey's sisters
would come over
joey uh
you know he'd come out with his shirt
off and
he's stretching me yeah you think i'm
gonna have one of your beers you know i
didn't
my daughters were like daddy get him out
of here
i'm like come on jazz
he's too smart for his own good he's
self-taught how to play the guitar
great
um
you know he reason
reads and speaks and and can understand
german
um
you know
calculus trigonometry all that he's they
were in honors they wanted to bump
joseph up and my uh one of my daughters
malicious they wanted to bump them up in
grades
you know and i we didn't we left them
where they were yeah i said did drugs
start for you in high school
joe yeah it uh
it started with
i guess you could say weed but really it
started with beer
and then weed
and then
pills and
you know and so forth you know
do you feel like it's a genetic thing
that you picked up from your family from
your dad from whoever
you know
is it are they saying it is genetic i
mean there's so many stories of
grandparents and their parents and then
this i think i could i would say maybe
the um the drinking might be
genetic but
with uh drugs i mean
i you know i went there and
you know sought them out to to see what
they were about um
i don't know if
if that was genetic or not yeah i
personally think that probably
you know with like i said with alcohol
it
probably is a little bit genetic like
the addictive behavior you know i i
think that's the wiring genetic right
right
you know it was a lot of fun man we we
laughed a lot you know uh my dad was old
school
very old school
to the point of you know he was honest
to a fault where
we're like man dad you gotta turn it
down you shouldn't say some of the
things you're saying you know but
but he was great you know he was he he
was a man you couldn't argue with
because he was
he really if he was wrong he'd admit it
so there was no argument and and if
he wasn't wrong you know he
he really stood his guns man and you
know
i mean he would tell me about living on
kensington
well
maybe in kensington uh
well it's a shame of some of those
things that you see it's actually to me
it's sad man
you know it living is a little bit of a
stretch i mean
you know we're alive um
we really don't have
direction like
goals and
uh
i don't i don't want i don't want to
take dreams but we don't have
like the end goal like
do this to get there
we're not
we're not sure
you know we're not
it's not all clear right now it's uh
it's just
it's definitely a struggle one thing
one thing joey and
his sisters and all of us pretty much
are or
basically we're realists you know where
you can look at something and people can
sugarcoat it and um
we see through it you know what i mean
and and it is what it is we chose to be
here
yeah we chose to be here right from the
right from the rip man it was dangerous
it wasn't what we thought you know i
mean i i i kind of it kind of was and it
kind of wasn't you know i wasn't
used to the shock of seeing
the violence the
you know people using the bathrooms just
anywhere
um not cleaning themselves
police are
different down here the police in bucks
county compared to philadelphia the
police are way different right i mean
they'll watch you shoot up and turn
their back
i mean
you know if they tolerate a lot but they
don't feel like dealing with it they'll
just turn their back and ignore it it's
it's totally i believe they're
overwhelmed you know i i truly do and
they're put in a position where this
this crap's been going on for years man
years so if to try to nip it in the bud
now
i think they're really going to have a
hard time you know um i think uh you
know we see we were still home when they
were talking about uh like a safe
shooting spot or something like that
i think uh
you know i don't know if that's the idea
or that's the the that would be nice
that's the answer but no i think it's
along those lines it would be there's
too many people for one safe shooting
site yeah there's too many people it
wouldn't i mean but it wouldn't work
a little more education maybe about you
know not as far as uh
you know social studies and science and
math i'm saying just to be aware man
there's there's people that have skills
you you'd see a a syringe filled with
blood and they'll pick it up and use it
you know and they don't know whose it is
and we're like you know you don't know
that that could have aids that could
have this that and they're like well i
already have this and that and i'll just
clean it and and
you know
i mean it it's heartbreaking you know i
mean i never
the the
i i've went through it before where i
didn't have heroin and you go through
withdrawal and and and it's
painful it's uh
desperate desperate everything goes
through your mind it's terrible it's
terrible i'd hate to see anybody go
through it
and
these people down here me and they just
uh
you know it's not that they want to go
through it but there's just so much
volume of people
and drugs everywhere that
they don't have to go out and get a job
you know what i mean because you
if this guy won't give it to you this
guy eventually will you know what i mean
or they'll walk around and pick stuff up
and it's like
you know man i mean i i don't know
i wouldn't know where to begin you know
that's a problem i wouldn't want you
know i mean um
you could see they you know
what blew my mind when i came and stayed
down here
is
they clean it man i mean it's dirty down
here and but you would be so surprised i
mean this stuff was you know about a
foot deep with trash and bile and waste
but tomorrow morning it's going to be
clean you know and it's it's
it's you know what's the word i'm
looking for it's it's inspiring i mean
to look at these people
and they're they go to work every
morning they clean it you know for
peanuts
and uh they feed everybody and it's just
i never expected
that they would be able to handle
this situation as much as you know i
never thought about it
and
like you said this is your first time
coming down man and it's a culture shock
you know if you never heard nothing
about it or you've never seen anything
on a negative side of you know
dark web you know you know what i'm
saying uh
things that are illegal
this place is
mind-blowing you know i mean there's
stuff people get away with the stuff
people
think about the stuff people say
you know i mean it's like wow you know
it's it it blows me away i
i wouldn't know what to do it's a whole
different level yeah i mean i really
wouldn't know what to do it's scary
as father and son is it more difficult
your father seeing your son in this
situation
i'll go first on this one for for me
it's great to have joey with me you know
because it's somebody i can always trust
it's someone i can lean on you know um
who i was just mentioning amy the the
mother of the other six babies she just
died you know we were together 21 years
and
when she died man that was my world
and uh
you know without joey who knows what
would have happened you know i don't
believe in suicide i
it never popped into my brain but
you know going out with a bang wouldn't
it
i just never expected it you know i've
been around death before and all that
and his mother died and but it was so we
we were all together every day
and it was so bam like a shock like oh
my god this happened to her but it could
happen to anybody it could happen to us
you know and then i get the looks where
you know people are like how could you
how could you get high with your son you
know what i mean
and it's like
first of all you haven't walked in my
shoes or his shoes you know you don't
know the story
joey's going to do what joey's going to
do he's his own man he's 28 years old so
he's going to do what he wants to do
regardless
um
he was using it before i was using it
you know
i came home to him using it
i'm not saying it's the right thing and
it's no excuse at all it's definitely
wrong for a father to
indulge the way we are you know with his
son you know maybe drink a beer watch
the game that's one thing
hard drugs it's i wouldn't advise it
it's bad it's terrible it's it's
crappy following
i'm not proud of it at all
you know um i i try to
teach joey street smart things you know
i
even though i had a good life you know i
was in trouble
for no reason at all you know i mean i i
was in glen mills when i was young
you know so i always dealt with the
um
i don't want to say always a criminal
element but
it's pretty much you know a criminal
element
and um
you know to see him
getting involved in it knowing where it
leads you know saying oh look at look at
me you know you don't want to be here
you don't you know
i want better things for you um
and joey you know he says i know dad and
i want better things for myself this is
something i want to do you know i don't
know if it's uh
he's got to get it out of his system i i
don't i don't know um
i could say stop and he wouldn't you
know um i could say stop and and if he
did that's you know that's that's great
um i i don't want to think of myself as
hypocritical because i've never told him
that i didn't do it and you know i don't
lie to him about things
that i do
um
and he he does know that
you know i i get upset
if i see him high or if i see him having
a hard time with something or even you
know just
thinking man joe you know i didn't want
this for you is it my fault you know um
there's just so much better joey can do
i understand the point that maybe he
does have to get it out of his system
you know millennials nowadays i don't
know what they think but
but uh you know hopefully
after all this because believe it or not
this whole experience
is humbling it really it the the people
though you know all the things i've said
about them
they blow your mind with
it it could just be
you know
someone who you think is a thug will say
something so
you know it'll uplifting you know just
keep your head up scott you know god's
on your back or
you know we're here for you your friends
are here for you got family if you need
this if you need that you know it's
stuff you'd never expect
and it happens every day
and to look at it i was like wow
you know there's a whole new like
underworld that you just don't see
until you're here
and you know the people don't get the
the respect or the um
i i don't know
they don't get the
hey good job that they deserve you know
because they're getting lumped into oh
that's all drugs and trash down there
you know there's a lot of people helping
a lot of people and and it goes on you
know homelessness the the drug use the
the panhandling there's you know
everybody's the hustle down here is
amazing man i mean if that's one thing
you know if an addict was to
change his mind and
put as much
you know
into
something legal or something productive
as he does with finding that fixed man
the world would just be a better place
you know because
the resourcefulness of some people is
you know
you know you'd never expect it
and it it only goes to the show you
really cannot judge a book by its cover
you know every day i'm surprised down
here
joe what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
28 years
well the most important thing
now
i'm
i'm almost 30.
um
yeah i used to act different obviously
as a teenager
younger 20s
now
i
i would say you know
there's tomorrow's another day
you know um
the only thing
that's guaranteed is change nothing's
nothing stays the same forever
and uh
you know
there's so many things you can't control
that
there's you shouldn't worry about
so many of them even though we do
but
you know um you still have hope that you
and your dad will get out of here
yeah absolutely what uh what do you say
absolutely hope for uh the future yeah
oh definitely yeah
it's uh
it's it's not always
you can imagine it's not always a great
feeling
seeing your your father and your your
loved one
uh you know out here destitute and uh
so you know at times suffering and
lost and
but
you know one thing
i do say
is that we have
more than a lot of people out here
because we have each other yeah and
you know it
people notice that it's not something
you can just take away you know
you know we'll we'll all die someday
but
until then we do have each other and
that's that's
a lot
excellent all right scott and joe thank
you so much for sharing your stories
hey um no problem at all and thank you
for uh you know the stuff i've seen of
your work
great work man thank you for bringing it
to the light you know because a lot of
the stuff is uh you know i don't know
what to say about taboo but some of the
stuff is you know
not spoke about as much as you know
maybe uh everything else yeah that was
so cool how
you know we're here on the other end of
it now yeah not just watching it on our
phone and right and it's that's just so
cool to be honest with you you know
i i would love after all this is said
and done the experience um
to help people somehow you know i know i
know that's the right thing to say and
it's cliche popular thing right right
but it really really
makes me feel better than i
than i've ever expected
to help somebody you know help somebody
in the jam and i don't mean you know get
them high or nothing because a lot of
times you know
i'm being older out here everybody calls
me pops because they heard him say hey
pops so now i'm pops out
because i say pop now everybody calls
him pop
so i don't know if it's because of the
uh
you know the terminology or the the
label pops
um but people
a lot of people more than i expected
ask for advice and i'm thinking
who am i to give advice you know but you
know a lot of people they they respect
the relationship me and joey have
um
you know they don't see when we go when
we leave you know the little arguments
in the bickering we have but they you
know they respect how
we look out for each other and and we
can do it every day day in and day out
you know there's not there's not days
that we don't argue it's you know we're
normal we're just in an abnormal place
you know like i said this is a very
abnormal place man it really is
uh you know this is definitely not oz
and you know you're you're over the
rainbow
and uh you know
it's a shame like i said when people
come down here you can walking down the
street you can say he's new she's new
he's new and the place just eats them up
and it chews them up and spits them out
man and it's a shame you just feel like
running and saying hey look hey just
what are you doing get the hell out of
here go down man do not be here when it
gets dark just go now that's like i said
we we don't stay in kensington you know
we come to our thing you know say hi to
our friends and whatnot
um
do our little hustle and and that's it
we get out of here at night we're gone
we learned that in the first two weeks
we
learned that it's dangerous man they're
beating people up they stab they shoot
they throw people in front of the trains
you know and like i said it's it's just
for no reason overwhelming for the uh
for law enforcement i i don't know how
they would do it or what they would do
some kind of task force some kind of
something but
you know these guys i've seen them turn
their heads so they don't have to deal
with i i think a lot of them are just
afraid
of the repercussion of doing something
you know i mean they they they do
something good to help
and then the rest of the week they're
going to be out here getting looked at
so uh
you know it lives here too yeah it's
definitely an experience out here um
not one everybody would uh you know get
through but
you know uh
i'm going to learn a lot when i'm flying
into this yeah i believe once it's all
said and over
that
it'll make us
a stronger person yeah i think sure
all right scott and joe thank you so
much for sharing your stories okay thank
you i wish you guys the best of luck
great thank you
you